these days to be an nba champion you're
probably gonna need to be a top
three-point shooting team and who better
to talk threes than the nba's all-time
leading three-point shooter ray allen hi
i'm rory allen yeah we know i already
said
that our story begins on february 7 1945
back when all shots were worth a mere
two points
that day the columbia university lions
were taking on the fordham rams in new
york city and the ncaa introduced the
world to the three-point shot
basketball would never be the same again
once the ncaa permanently adopted the
triple in 1986
the three-point shot mitigated the
advantage taller stronger players were
well born with sure they were good small
players but incentivizing shots from
distance level the playing field or
should i say hardwood court
fast forward 70 years and the three
point shot is the shot and ray allen
knows this rey is the most prolific
three-point shooter in nba history
for now what the hell
and ray like all basketball greats is a
student of the game when did the
three-point jacket introduced to
professional basketball it all started
with the american basketball association
better known as the aba
time out for all you non-basketball fans
out there the ncaa is a national
collegiate athletic association that's
college basketball the aba a pro league
was a sort of anti-mba until emerged
with the nba in 1976.
fall in the aba featured a flashier
version of basketball with a colorful
ball dunks
and of course
the three-point shot
and for that you can thank then-aba
commissioner george miken who wanted to
give the smaller player a chance to
score and open up the defense to make
the game more enjoyable to fans
exactly
so the nba adopted it pretty much right
away right it took a while it wasn't
until 1979 when boston celtic chris ford
my first nba coach hit the first
three-point side in an nba game the
first of over 380 000 threes made in nba
history
we take a break from our regularly
scheduled programming to bring you the
art of the three-point shot by mr walter
ray allen jr the key to three-point shot
is normal you are on the floor before
you get the ball nobody likes a long
tube
you need a great knee bend
gather yourself
next you need great lift straight up and
down
and of course to top it all off you need
an immaculate follow-through
it's so easy anyone can do it
[Music]
almost anyone
come on little buddy you got this
get in there you know your game might be
horseshoes